Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode features violent sexual crimes against a minor. It won't be suitable for all listeners. Lee Lee's double-barrelled name was a happy accident. She was born Lee Renee Mears on July 24, 1975, to parents Robin and Robert.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集内容涉及针对未成年人的暴力性犯罪，不适合所有听众。李·李（Lee Lee）的双重名字是一个美丽的巧合。她于1975年7月24日出生，原名李·蕾妮·米尔斯（Lee Renee Mears），父母是罗宾（Robin）和罗伯特（Robert）。
Theirs was a tumultuous marriage that only persisted due to their mutual love of their daughter, but ultimately ended in divorce when Lee was 7 years old. After her birth parents separated, Lee's mother entered into a de facto relationship with a man whose surname was Lee. The couple had a daughter in 1983, whom they named Jesse. Lee wanted to share her younger sister's surname, and loved the fact that it would give her her duplicate name. She liked her unique name so much, she kept it after her mother ended that relationship.
他们的婚姻生活动荡不安，仅因对女儿的共同爱意而勉强维持，但最终在李7岁时以离婚告终。父母分居后，李的母亲与一名姓李的男子开始了事实婚姻。这对夫妇于1983年生下一个女儿，取名杰西（Jesse）。李想和妹妹共用一个姓氏，并且很喜欢这会让她拥有重复的名字。她非常喜欢这个独特的名字，以至于在母亲结束那段关系后，她依然保留了这个姓氏。
Robin was close to her oldest daughter, and took Lee, aged 10, on a two-month holiday to Sri Lanka to experience her familial heritage. By 1986, Robin and her two daughters had moved to a house on Fullerton Street in Fern Bay, a working-class suburb in the Hunter region of New South Wales. First south of Fern Bay was Stockton, technically a suburb of the city of Newcastle. It lay across the harbour mouth of the Hunter River, meaning anyone wanting to get there from Newcastle would either have to take a five-minute ferry ride or a half-hour drive. Its isolation from the city gave Stockton more of a provincial atmosphere, with an insular
罗宾与大女儿关系亲密，曾带着10岁的李去斯里兰卡度假两个月，让她体验家族的文化遗产。到1986年，罗宾和两个女儿搬到了新南威尔士州亨特地区一个工人阶级郊区——芬湾（Fern Bay）的富勒顿街。芬湾南边是斯托克顿（Stockton），在行政上属于纽卡斯尔市。它位于亨特河的入海口对面，这意味着任何想从纽卡斯尔去那里的人，要么乘坐五分钟的渡轮，要么开车半小时。与城市的隔绝使斯托克顿更具地方色彩，拥有一个封闭
and close-knit community. The township was characterised by low incomes and high unemployment. It was while living in Fern Bay that Robin met local man Brad Shearman, who became Lee and Jesse's stepfather. Lee was a popular and outgoing girl, and made friends easily at both Stockton Primary School and later at Newcastle High. By age 14, she had aspirations to become a veterinarian and was well-behaved at school, but exhibited a rebellious streak with her mum and stepdad.
且紧密的社区。该镇的特点是低收入和高失业率。正是在住在芬湾期间，罗宾结识了当地人布拉德·希尔曼（Brad Shearman），他后来成为了李和杰西的继父。李是一个受欢迎且外向的女孩，在斯托克顿小学和后来的纽卡斯尔高中都很容易交到朋友。14岁时，她立志成为一名兽医，在学校表现良好，但与母亲和继父相处时却表现出叛逆的一面。
In these moments, it was clear she had inherited her mother's strength of character and her biological father's single-minded determination. Nevertheless, her mother and grandmother regarded Lee as a typical teenager who cared deeply for her family. It was a warm spring evening on Friday, November 3, 1989, and Lee Lee was excited. She was going to her first late-night party to celebrate the 16th birthday of one of the local boys, Jason Robertson. More than 50 youths would be in attendance, mostly year-ten students from Newcastle High.
在这些时刻，很明显她继承了母亲坚强的性格和生父那种执着的决心。尽管如此，她的母亲和祖母仍认为李是一个深爱家人的典型青少年。那是1989年11月3日，星期五，一个温暖的春夜，李·李非常兴奋。她要去参加她的第一个深夜派对，庆祝当地男孩杰森·罗伯逊（Jason Robertson）的16岁生日。届时将有超过50名年轻人参加，大多是纽卡斯尔高中的十年级学生。
But some younger girls had received an invitation too. Lee was one of them, even though she was only 14 years old and in year 8. This made her feel important and mature, as only a handful of girls her age had been invited. The party was being held at the old North Stockton Surf Club, a popular venue for such events. The one-story red brick building was positioned on a large patch of open lawn, with its rear facing the Stockton Waterfront a short walk away. Both Lee's mother and stepfather were apprehensive, as the invitation said the party was an all-night
但一些更小的女孩也收到了邀请。李就是其中之一，尽管她当时只有14岁，还在读八年级。这让她感到自己很重要且成熟，因为只有少数同龄女孩受邀。派对在旧北斯托克顿冲浪俱乐部举行，这是此类活动的常用场地。这座单层红砖建筑坐落在一大片开阔的草坪上，后方朝向不远处斯托克顿的海滨。李的母亲和继父都很担心，因为邀请函上写着派对将通宵进行
affair from 7pm until dawn. It also stipulated, bring your own, which suggested there would be alcohol present. But Lee had been persuasive and convinced them that the night could be viewed as a test. If she behaved herself and was ready to be picked up at the surf club at exactly 11pm, she would be given more freedom to attend other parties and social events. If she wasn't waiting at the allotted time, she would be grounded and banned from going to the upcoming dance at Newcastle High, which Lee desperately wanted to attend. There wasn't a lot to do for teens in the area, as the discos that used to be held at
从晚上7点一直持续到黎明。上面还规定“自带酒水”，这意味着现场会有酒精。但李很有说服力，她让他们相信这个夜晚可以被视为一次考验。如果她表现良好，并且在晚上11点准时在冲浪俱乐部等候接送，她以后就能获得更多参加派对和社交活动的自由。如果她没有在指定时间等候，她就会被禁足，并被禁止参加即将到来的纽卡斯尔高中舞会，而李非常想参加那个舞会。当地青少年的娱乐活动并不多，因为过去在
the Masonic Hall had come to an end, and the local movie house had shut down. There were the occasional gatherings at the surf club on a Friday night, where they would listen to the local band practice while drinking beer or cask wine acquired by an older sibling or friend. Otherwise, they would all hang out at Roberto's Pizza Bar, which had arcade games to play. Lee's social life until then consisted of going to the movies in Newcastle, roller skating, and hanging out with friends. Jason Robertson's 16th birthday was her first real party, and she was going with a couple
共济会大厅举办的迪斯科舞会已经停止，当地的电影院也关门了。周五晚上，冲浪俱乐部偶尔会有聚会，他们会一边听当地乐队排练，一边喝着从年长的兄弟姐妹或朋友那里弄来的啤酒或盒装葡萄酒。否则，他们就会聚在罗伯托披萨店（Roberto's Pizza Bar），那里有街机游戏可以玩。在那之前，李的社交生活仅限于去纽卡斯尔看电影、滑旱冰以及和朋友闲逛。杰森·罗伯逊的16岁生日是她参加的第一个真正的派对，她和几个
of girlfriends. She was secretly thrilled to be seeing the boy she had a crush on, who would be playing in Cardinal Sin, the local band that was the Knights Entertainment. She assured her mother that adult supervision had been arranged for the event, and that she knew most of the kids at the party. At 7pm, Robin dropped her daughter off at Roberto's Pizza Bar, where Lee had planned to meet her fellow party-going friends. The three girls would then walk the two kilometres to the surf club.
女朋友一起去。她暗自兴奋，因为能见到她暗恋的男孩，他将在当地乐队“红衣主教之罪”（Cardinal Sin）中演奏，该乐队是骑士娱乐公司（Knights Entertainment）旗下的。她向母亲保证，活动已经安排了成人监督，而且她认识派对上的大多数孩子。晚上7点，罗宾把女儿送到罗伯托披萨店，李计划在那里与参加派对的朋友们会合。三个女孩随后步行两公里前往冲浪俱乐部。
Robin waved Lee goodbye, and reminded her to be ready to be picked up by her stepfather four hours later at the agreed meeting spot, or there would be consequences. Just before 11 o'clock that night, Brad Shearman left home to go and pick up his stepdaughter from the North Stockton Surf Club. He returned over an hour later, alone and agitated, telling Robin that Lee had not been at the agreed meeting spot. He went out again to look for her and checked the building where the party was being held, finding drunk and drug-affected teenagers throughout and spilling onto the beach.
罗宾向李挥手告别，并提醒她四小时后在约定的地点等候继父接她，否则会有后果。那天晚上11点前不久，布拉德·希尔曼离开家去北斯托克顿冲浪俱乐部接继女。一个多小时后，他独自一人焦急地回到家，告诉罗宾李没有在约定的地点。他再次出门寻找她，并检查了举办派对的建筑，发现到处都是喝醉和吸毒的青少年，甚至溢到了海滩上。
They were in various states of undress, screaming and carrying on, with some vomiting in the bushes or passed out in the gutter. He cited around 15 or 16 cases of beer and evidence of cannabis usage. Brad had discovered the promised adult supervision consisted of two older male teenagers, an 18 and 19-year-old, who had been tasked as bouncers for the event in exchange for a case of beer. Brad asked the party-goers about Lee, but none could offer him a coherent answer, and nobody seemed to know where she was. Someone suggested she might have gone home early.
他们衣衫不整，尖叫打闹，有些人呕吐在灌木丛中，或者醉倒在阴沟里。他看到了大约15到16箱啤酒和吸食大麻的痕迹。布拉德发现所谓的成人监督竟然是两名年长的男青少年，一个18岁，一个19岁，他们以一箱啤酒为代价担任活动的保安。布拉德询问派对参与者关于李的情况，但没人能给他一个连贯的回答，似乎没人知道她在哪里。有人建议她可能提前回家了。
Brad drove home in case she had walked or got a lift there, but upon realizing she hadn't, he headed out again. He drove around the streets before returning to the surf club where the party was winding up. There was still no sign of Lee by 2am, so he retrieved his three-wheeled motorbike, enabling him to scale the sand tracks and dunes along the beach with ease. Yet, Lee was still nowhere to be seen. Brad returned home, assuming his stepdaughter had gone to a friend's place to spend the
布拉德开车回家，看看她是否步行或搭车回去了，但意识到她没回来后，他又出发了。他在街道上开车转了一圈，然后回到派对即将结束的冲浪俱乐部。凌晨2点仍不见李的踪影，于是他取回了他的三轮摩托车，这使他能够轻松地在海滩沿线的沙道和沙丘上行驶。然而，依然看不到李。布拉德回到家，以为继女去了朋友家过夜，
night, or perhaps fallen asleep on the shoreline somewhere. It wasn't unusual for parties held at the surf club to end on the beach and carry on until the next morning. As far as Robin was concerned, her eldest daughter had failed her first party test. There would be no dance, and she had a lot of explaining to do. Lee still hadn't arrived home by the next morning, so Brad recommenced the search while Robin rang her daughter's friends to find out if she had a sleepover. Brad returned to the surf club, and at 9.15am spotted a group of people standing less than
或者在海岸线的某个地方睡着了。冲浪俱乐部举办的派对在海滩上结束并持续到第二天早上并不罕见。在罗宾看来，她的大女儿没能通过第一次派对考验。舞会去不成了，而且她得好好解释一番。第二天早上李还没回家，布拉德便重新开始搜寻，而罗宾则打电话给女儿的朋友，询问她是否在谁家过夜。布拉德回到冲浪俱乐部，上午9点15分，他看到一群人站在不到
100 meters away, talking animatedly as they stared at something on the sand below. Brad rushed over and realised they were looking at Lee. She was sprawled out on the sand, naked. Her legs were spread apart, and her face almost unrecognisable. She was still wearing her Dunlop volley shoes and pink socks, but her shorts and underwear had been pulled down and were around her right ankle. The remainder of her alcohol-soaked clothes were found nearby. Her face was covered in blood, having sustained several severe blows to the left side of her
100米远的地方，一边盯着沙滩上的某样东西，一边激动地交谈。布拉德冲过去，意识到他们看到的是李。她赤身裸体地瘫倒在沙滩上。她的双腿张开，脸部几乎无法辨认。她还穿着邓禄普（Dunlop）运动鞋和粉色袜子，但她的短裤和内衣被拉了下来，挂在右脚踝处。她那浸透酒精的其余衣物在附近被发现。她的脸部布满血迹，头部左侧遭受了数次重击。
skull. A blood-stained rock of concrete weighing six kilograms was located nearby. There were also bruise marks around her neck. An autopsy would later reveal injuries to her genital region, consistent with repeated violent intrusion. Tucked inside Lee's shorts pocket was the invitation to the 16th birthday party she had attended the night before. Lee's body had been discovered by the birthday boy, Jason Robertson, who had helped Brad
附近发现了一块重达六公斤、沾有血迹的混凝土块。她的脖子上也有淤青。尸检后来显示她的生殖区域有伤痕，与反复的暴力侵入一致。李的短裤口袋里塞着她前一天晚上参加的16岁生日派对的邀请函。李的尸体是由寿星杰森·罗伯逊发现的，他前一天晚上曾帮助布拉德
Shearman search for her the night before, but the darkness shrouding the sand dunes made it difficult for them to see anything at that time. Jason had received a frantic call the next morning from Lee's mother, telling him that her daughter hadn't returned home, so he had gone looking for her along the beach when the sun came up. Newcastle police arrived at the beach and declared the side a crime scene. They were aware there was a party at the North Stockton Surf Club the night prior and had carried out a routine check of the event at 8.30pm, but everything seemed in order at
希尔曼寻找她，但沙丘笼罩的黑暗使他们当时很难看清任何东西。杰森第二天早上接到了李母亲打来的焦急电话，告诉他女儿没有回家，于是他在太阳升起时沿着海滩寻找她。纽卡斯尔警方抵达海滩，并将现场封锁为犯罪现场。他们知道前一天晚上北斯托克顿冲浪俱乐部有派对，并在晚上8点30分对活动进行了例行检查，但当时一切似乎都很正常。
the time. Following the discovery of Lee Lee's body, they sought to identify every person who had attended the party, asking birthday boy Jason Robertson for a list of invitees. They spoke with residents who lived in the area and they reported that the party had been mostly subdued, but some mentioned hearing a girl screaming and a man swearing loudly before everything went quiet. Reporters for the Sydney Morning Herald newspaper spoke to two girls who claimed to be Lee's best friends, but who had not been at the party.
在发现李·李的尸体后，他们试图确认参加派对的每一个人，并向寿星杰森·罗伯逊索要了一份受邀者名单。他们与住在该地区的居民交谈，居民们报告说派对大部分时间都很安静，但有些人提到听到一个女孩的尖叫声和一个男人大声咒骂，随后一切都安静了下来。《悉尼先驱晨报》的记者采访了两个自称是李最好的朋友的女孩，但她们并没有参加派对。
One described to Lee as, a very attractive girl, which tended to make her the target of a lot of boys and we used to have to protect her. As neither girl had been with Lee the previous night, she added, maybe Lee thought she could protect herself. Girls were reluctant to believe their youth could do anything so heinous, with the owner of Roberto's pizza bar stating, I know these kids well, they're pretty responsible. Over the following days, the police tried to piece together what exactly occurred the night of the party.
其中一人将李描述为“一个非常有吸引力的女孩，这往往使她成为许多男孩的目标，我们过去常常不得不保护她”。由于两个女孩前一天晚上都没有和李在一起，她补充说：“也许李以为她能保护自己。”女孩们不愿相信她们的同龄人会做出如此令人发指的事情，罗伯托披萨店的老板说：“我很了解这些孩子，他们相当负责任。”在接下来的几天里，警方试图拼凑出派对当晚究竟发生了什么。
Over 50 teenagers were questioned in relation to the event and a picture began to emerge of a wild party. Most attendees were between the ages of 13 and 18, but there were a couple there as young as 10. However, their investigation was hampered by what the police referred to as a wall of silence from witnesses reluctant to talk about anything that could get them or their friends in trouble. As many were affected by alcohol or drugs on the night, their recollections were impaired
超过50名青少年就该事件接受了询问，一幅狂野派对的画面开始浮现。大多数参加者年龄在13到18岁之间，但也有几个年仅10岁的孩子。然而，他们的调查受到了警方所称的“沉默之墙”的阻碍，证人们不愿谈论任何可能让他们或朋友陷入麻烦的事情。由于许多人在当晚受到酒精或毒品的影响，他们的记忆力受损，
and some invented stories or flat out lied about being there. Some witnesses gave as many as three different accounts of key events. Investigators were also up against the general distrust of police amongst the boys of Stockton, who lived by a code of mateship. Parents of the party-goers were equally dismissive and closed ranks due to apathy or in order to protect their children. One caller phoned a talkback radio station and said, It's un-Australian to dob in a mate.
有些人编造故事或公然撒谎说自己当时在场。一些证人对关键事件提供了多达三种不同的说法。调查人员还面临着斯托克顿男孩中普遍存在的对警察的不信任，他们信奉一种“兄弟情谊”准则。派对参与者的父母也同样不予理睬，由于冷漠或为了保护孩子而结成统一战线。一位听众给谈话广播电台打电话说：“举报朋友是不符合澳大利亚精神的。”
Head of the North Region Crime Squad Homicide Unit, Detective Sergeant Lance Chaffee, told reporters, I'm looking at 60 suspects, but only two parents have bothered to contact us to assist us in what their kid might have seen. They theorized that some parents might have felt guilty for allowing their children to attend such an unruly event and Lee's murder reflected on their inability to properly supervise them. Gradually, investigators were able to piece together a timeline of events from witnesses
北部地区犯罪小组凶杀案组负责人、侦探警长兰斯·查菲（Lance Chaffee）告诉记者：“我正在调查60名嫌疑人，但只有两名家长主动联系我们，协助我们了解他们的孩子可能看到了什么。”他们推测，一些家长可能因为允许孩子参加如此混乱的活动而感到内疚，而李的谋杀案反映了他们无法妥善监管孩子。渐渐地，调查人员能够从证人那里拼凑出事件的时间线，
who had been reassured that nobody would find out that they had talked to the police. They were able to ascertain that after Lee was dropped off at Roberto's pizza bar, she had met with two of her friends as planned, but also a third friend who bought a bottle of bourbon. Lee was an inexperienced drinker and consumed half the bottle with Coca-Cola. By the time the group arrived at the surf club, the liquor had impacted Lee significantly and she was staggering and slurring her words. She showed event bouncer, 18-year-old Matthew Webster her invitation and he marked her arm
这些证人被保证没人会发现他们向警方提供了信息。他们确定，李在罗伯托披萨店下车后，按计划与两个朋友会合，但也遇到了第三个买了瓶波本威士忌的朋友。李是一个没有经验的饮酒者，和可乐一起喝了半瓶。当这群人到达冲浪俱乐部时，酒精已经对李产生了重大影响，她步履蹒跚，说话含糊不清。她向活动保安、18岁的马修·韦伯斯特（Matthew Webster）出示了邀请函，他用绿色记号笔在她的手臂上
with a green texta and granted her entry inside, where the party was just getting started. Known locally as Fat Matt due to his 110kg frame, Webster told a reporter who interviewed him days after the party. The problem with Stockton is that there is nothing for us to do at night, implying that when a party was on, everyone let loose. One of his friends added, Everyone reckons we're all bad over here now, but we're no different from teenagers in any other suburb. The murderer could have come from anywhere.
做了标记并准许她进入，此时派对才刚刚开始。韦伯斯特因其110公斤的体格在当地被称为“胖马特”（Fat Matt），他在派对几天后接受记者采访时说：“斯托克顿的问题在于我们晚上无事可做”，暗示当有派对时，每个人都会放纵自己。他的一个朋友补充说：“现在每个人都认为我们这里的人都很坏，但我们和任何其他郊区的青少年没什么不同。凶手可能来自任何地方。”
When the police visited the event at around 8.30pm, the party goers hid their alcohol in the sandhills so nothing appeared amiss. Birthday boy Jason Robertson admitted there had been some drinking, but maintained it was minimal and most of the alcohol had been taken by his older friends. He said, Lee had a couple of drinks, but most of us were just drinking Coke. He complained that he could barely leave his house because he felt the town was whispering and pointing at him, knowing it was his party where the murder happened. From the witness accounts, investigators zeroed in on one incident they believed might have
当警察在晚上8点30分左右访问活动现场时，派对参与者把酒藏在沙丘里，所以看起来没什么异常。寿星杰森·罗伯逊承认确实有一些饮酒，但坚称那是极少数，大部分酒精都被他的年长朋友拿走了。他说：“李喝了几杯，但我们大多数人只是在喝可乐。”他抱怨说，他几乎不敢离开家，因为他觉得镇上的人都在对他窃窃私语并指指点点，因为大家都知道谋杀案发生在他的派对上。根据证人的陈述，调查人员将注意力集中在他们认为可能与犯罪有关的一起事件上。
been linked to the crime. Several female attendees said that around 9pm, Lee had left the surf club to go for a walk to the beach and might have been accompanied by a male. She returned a little while later, extremely distressed, telling two of her friends that she had been raped and was worried about being pregnant. They sat her down at a table and attempted to comfort her, though were skeptical of her claims that she was heavily intoxicated. They asked if she wanted them to call her parents.
几名女性参加者说，晚上9点左右，李离开了冲浪俱乐部去海滩散步，可能有一个男性陪同。过了一会儿，她回来时非常痛苦，告诉两个朋友她被强奸了，并担心自己会怀孕。她们让她坐在桌旁试图安慰她，尽管对她声称自己醉得很厉害表示怀疑。她们问她是否需要她们给她的父母打电话。
Lee declined the offer and stumbled back outside. Newspaper reports stated that investigators believed Lee Lee had been raped several times and that more than one person was involved, though they were uncertain whether the rape and murder were linked. Several printed stories about the prevalence of gang rapes in small industrial towns such as Stockton, with the Boys Will Be Boys mentality strong in the 1980s. Victims of sex crimes were seen as having deserved their treatment or perceived as having done something to bring it on themselves.
李拒绝了提议，跌跌撞撞地回到外面。报纸报道称，调查人员认为李·李被多次强奸，且不止一人参与，尽管他们不确定强奸和谋杀是否有关联。几家报纸刊登了关于斯托克顿等小型工业城镇普遍存在轮奸案的故事，1980年代“男孩就是男孩”（Boys Will Be Boys）的心态非常强烈。性犯罪的受害者被视为罪有应得，或者被认为做了什么事才招致这种对待。
Some were quoted as not reporting their rape due to shame and the fear of being blamed, especially if they were under the influence of alcohol or drugs at the time. Lee Lee was frank and forthright and had told her mother that she planned on being a virgin until she was 16 years old. Post-mortem results indicated that she was a virgin before the party, but during the course of the night she had endured extreme sexual violence. Despite this, some locals questioned whether she had been raped at all, with one resident telling a reporter,
一些人被引用说，由于羞耻和害怕被指责，她们没有报告自己的强奸遭遇，特别是如果她们当时受到酒精或毒品影响的话。李·李坦率直言，曾告诉母亲她打算在16岁之前保持处女之身。尸检结果显示，她在派对前是处女，但在当晚的过程中，她遭受了极端的性暴力。尽管如此，一些当地人质疑她是否真的被强奸了，一位居民告诉记者：
Yes, it's a terrible thing, but I hear she was a bit of a sleep around. Lee Lee's funeral was held on November 9, 1989, with her biological father Robert Mears and her stepfather Brad Shearman acting as pallbearers. One of Lee's favourite songs, If I Could Turn Back Time, by American pop singer Sher was played to the large gathering of mourners, many of whom were Lee's friends. She was buried at Stockton General Cemetery under a heart-shaped headstone that read, Within our hearts, memories of you will live on forever. After Lee was buried, allegations and gossip in Stockton intensified.
“是的，这是一件可怕的事情，但我听说她有点随便。”李·李的葬礼于1989年11月9日举行，她的生父罗伯特·米尔斯和继父布拉德·希尔曼担任护柩者。李最喜欢的歌曲之一、美国流行歌手雪儿（Cher）演唱的《如果我能时光倒流》（If I Could Turn Back Time）在哀悼者聚集的大厅里播放，其中许多人是李的朋友。她被安葬在斯托克顿公墓，墓碑呈心形，上面写着：“在我们心中，关于你的记忆将永远长存。”李下葬后，斯托克顿的指控和流言愈演愈烈。
Nearly everyone in town had a theory as to who was responsible for Lee's murder. Stockton's girls lived in fear of a murderer on the loose, whereas boys started fighting amongst themselves, accusing one another of speaking to the police. On November 12, nine days after Lee's murder, newspapers were reporting new leads in the case. Quote, Detectives want to trace two schoolgirls who fought off attackers trying to abduct them, the night Newcastle schoolgirl Lee Lee was raped and murdered. Police believe there may be a connection between Lee Lee's brutal murder and the attempted abduction.
镇上几乎每个人都有关于谁应对李的谋杀负责的理论。斯托克顿的女孩们生活在凶手逍遥法外的恐惧中，而男孩们则开始互相争斗，指责对方与警方交谈。11月12日，即李被谋杀九天后，报纸报道了案件的新线索。引文：“侦探们想要追踪两名女学生，她们在纽卡斯尔女学生李·李被强奸和谋杀的那天晚上，击退了试图绑架她们的袭击者。警方认为李·李的残忍谋杀案与这起未遂绑架案之间可能存在联系。”
The schoolgirls managed to save themselves when a gang tried to drag them into a car about 3am on the morning of Saturday, November 4. Nothing came of that lead, and it joined the increasing pile of lies, half truths and secrecy that dogged the investigation. Meanwhile, investigators continued to work diligently to uncover the truth of what occurred at Jason Robertson's 16th birthday party. Witnesses alleged that event bouncer, 18-year-old Matthew Webster had told other boys early in the night, quote, we're going to get Lee pissed and all go through her. A male 15-year-old attendee who can't be named for legal reasons was overheard
当一个团伙在11月4日星期六凌晨3点左右试图将她们拖进一辆车时，女学生们设法自救。那条线索没有下文，它加入了阻碍调查的谎言、半真半假的事实和秘密的堆积中。与此同时，调查人员继续努力工作，以揭开杰森·罗伯逊16岁生日派对上究竟发生了什么。证人声称，活动保安、18岁的马修·韦伯斯特在当晚早些时候告诉其他男孩，引文：“我们要把李灌醉，然后轮流上她。”一名因法律原因不能透露姓名的15岁男性参加者被听到
saying that he was going to, quote, fuck Lee. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to the 15-year-old male as Corey. As people were arriving to the party, Corey had asked another male attendee, were all the baldies coming tonight? Baldies was a colloquialism used to describe young girls who hadn't yet grown pubic hair. It was common practice for some of the older boys to invite underage girls as young as 10 to parties for the purpose of getting them drunk and taking advantage of them. After Corey was observed taking Lee towards the beach, she returned to the surf club a while later crying with blood between her legs. She told her friends that Corey had raped her and that she hated him. When questioned by police, Corey claimed that Lee had initiated the walk
说他打算，引文：“干李。”为了清晰起见，案卷将把这名15岁男性称为科里（Corey）。当人们到达派对时，科里曾问另一名男性参加者：“今晚所有的‘秃头’（Baldies）都会来吗？”“秃头”是一个口语词，用来形容还没长阴毛的年轻女孩。一些年长的男孩邀请年仅10岁的未成年女孩参加派对，目的是让她们喝醉并占她们便宜，这是一种常见的做法。在科里被观察到带着李走向海滩后，她过了一会儿回到冲浪俱乐部，双腿间带着血迹哭泣。她告诉朋友科里强奸了她，她恨他。当被警方询问时，科里声称是李主动发起了他们一起的散步
they took together as well as the sexual activity that came afterwards. After informing others what Corey had done, Lee headed back outside. Several male attendees began teasing and insulting her, and several accosted her for sex. When she refused, she was pushed to the ground as a group of upwards of 10 boys stood in a semicircle around her. One of the boys involved told police. They all had twist tops in their hands and they were pouring beer over her head and body and yelling abuse at her like, you stupid bush pig slut and things like that. I walked over to her and said, get up you stupid bitch. I laughed but I didn't pour any beer on her. Another participant Another participant implicated event bouncers Matthew Webster and the guy Wilson quote,
以及随后的性行为。在告诉别人科里做了什么后，李回到外面。几名男性参加者开始嘲笑和侮辱她，几个人上前要求与她发生性关系。当她拒绝时，她被推倒在地，一群多达10个男孩围成半圆站在她周围。其中一名参与者告诉警方：“他们手里都拿着扭盖瓶，他们把啤酒倒在她的头上和身上，并对她大喊大叫，比如‘你这个愚蠢的丛林猪荡妇’之类的。我走过去对她说，‘起来，你这个愚蠢的婊子’。我笑了，但我没有往她身上倒啤酒。”另一名参与者指控活动保安马修·韦伯斯特和盖伊·威尔逊（Guy Wilson），引文：
while I was standing with them over Lee, I heard Webster say things like get that into your slut and take that your slut. Wilson said the same things. Lee just lay there the whole time. She did not say anything but she was rolling around. The group then kicked Lee around the years, quote, pretty hard, though a female attendee claimed they were kicking her pretty hard, but not as hard as they could have. Once the group stopped, Lee slowly got up and staggered across the path and picked up an empty beer bottle. Her assailants were still laughing at her, prompting Lee to throw the bottle in their direction, though it didn't hit anyone. Bouncer Guy Wilson picked up the bottle and
“当我站在他们身边看着李时，我听到韦伯斯特说诸如‘把那个塞进你的荡妇里，拿着那个，你这个荡妇’之类的话。威尔逊也说了同样的话。李一直躺在那里。她什么也没说，但她在翻滚。”随后，这群人开始踢李，引文：“踢得很重”，尽管一名女性参加者声称他们踢她踢得很重，但并没有他们能做到的那么重。当这群人停下来后，李慢慢站起来，蹒跚着穿过小路，捡起一个空啤酒瓶。袭击者们还在嘲笑她，促使李向他们的方向扔瓶子，尽管没有击中任何人。保安盖伊·威尔逊捡起瓶子并
threw it back at Lee, hitting her on the leg. The attack was witnessed by approximately 40 or so youths that were milling about outside. Lee returned to the surf club where another 30 or so attendees were still inside and began vomiting. The band stopped playing and one of its members joined in the assault spitting his beer onto her. Another boy told police, I saw Lee come into the hall and she came up to us and we were calling her a slut, mole, bitch and we poured beers over her and spat on her and I pushed her with my hands. While I was doing it, she was crying and she got up and walked out. The last time they saw Lee was around 10.15pm as she headed off towards the beach alone. As word of Lee's treatment at the party spread around town, parents warned their sons to keep
扔回给李，击中了她的腿。这次袭击被大约40名在外面徘徊的年轻人目睹。李回到冲浪俱乐部，那里还有大约30名参加者在里面，并开始呕吐。乐队停止了演奏，其中一名成员加入了袭击，把啤酒吐在她身上。另一个男孩告诉警方：“我看到李走进大厅，她走到我们面前，我们叫她荡妇、婊子，我们把啤酒倒在她身上并向她吐口水，我用手推了她。当我这样做时，她在哭，她站起来走了出去。”他们最后一次见到李是在晚上10点15分左右，当时她独自一人朝海滩走去。随着李在派对上受到的待遇在镇上传开，家长们警告他们的儿子保持
their mouths shut and spun a different version of events, in which Lee had attended the party intending to get drunk and have sex with the boys there. Those suspected of leaking information to police were bullied, attacked or ostracized. The names of the young men who publicly assaulted and humiliated Lee were shared around town, with some locals expecting them to be brought to justice for their actions. Their anger arose from the fact that at least half the party, both boys and girls, witnessed what happened to Lee, yet no one went to her defense and nearly all of them refused to come forward afterwards to assist the police investigation. The corroborating witness accounts enabled investigators to narrow in on three party-goers that might have had a part to play
沉默，并编造了另一个版本的事件，即李参加派对是为了喝醉并与那里的男孩发生性关系。那些被怀疑向警方泄露信息的人受到欺凌、攻击或排斥。公开袭击和羞辱李的年轻男子的名字在镇上传开，一些当地人期望他们因自己的行为受到法律制裁。他们的愤怒源于这样一个事实：派对上至少有一半的人，包括男孩和女孩，目睹了李身上发生的事情，但没有人站出来保护她，而且事后几乎所有人都拒绝站出来协助警方调查。相互印证的证人陈述使调查人员能够锁定三名可能参与了
in Lee Lee's murder. Police found Corey, the 15-year-old alleged to have raped Lee outside Roberto's pizza bar. Event bouncer, 19-year-old Guy Wilson, was on his way home from the Gladstone Hotel when he was approached by police. And his companion, Matthew Webster, was sitting on a fence out the front of a friend's home when police officers asked him to accompany them to clear up a few things. Neither Corey nor Guy Wilson were able to offer alibis to account for their specific actions and whereabouts throughout Jason Robertson's birthday party. Matthew Webster claimed he had left the event early to go drink at a local pub before meeting up with friends at Roberto's pizza bar. Both he and Wilson were of legal drinking age and admitted to supplying the
李·李谋杀案的派对参与者。警方在罗伯托披萨店外找到了据称强奸了李的15岁少年科里。活动保安、19岁的盖伊·威尔逊在从格拉德斯通酒店（Gladstone Hotel）回家的路上被警方拦截。而他的同伴马修·韦伯斯特当时正坐在朋友家门前的栅栏上，警察要求他陪同他们去澄清一些事情。科里和盖伊·威尔逊都无法提供不在场证明来解释他们在杰森·罗伯逊生日派对期间的具体行为和行踪。马修·韦伯斯特声称他提前离开了活动，去当地一家酒吧喝酒，然后在罗伯托披萨店与朋友会合。他和威尔逊都已达到法定饮酒年龄，并承认提供了
beer and cannabis for the party. Webster's pub-related alibi did not check out and he admitted he was not being honest. All three youths were charged with various offenses relating to events that took place at the party. Webster and Wilson were charged with common assault pertaining to the group attack on Lee, with the latter also charged for supplying cannabis to two teenagers. Corey was charged with sexual intercourse with a child between the ages of 10 and 16 and also supplying cannabis. None were charged in relation to Lee's murder. Corey, being underage, was released into the custody of his mother, whereas Webster and Wilson were kept in police custody overnight. They were bailed by a magistrate the following day for $1,000 and released into the care of their
派对所需的啤酒和大麻。韦伯斯特关于酒吧的不在场证明经核实不成立，他承认自己没有说实话。这三名青少年都因与派对上发生的事件有关的各种罪行受到指控。韦伯斯特和威尔逊被控普通袭击罪，涉及对李的集体攻击，后者还因向两名青少年提供大麻而被指控。科里被控与10至16岁之间的儿童发生性关系，并提供大麻。没有人因李的谋杀案受到指控。科里因未成年被交由其母亲监护，而韦伯斯特和威尔逊则被警方拘留过夜。第二天，地方法官以1000美元的保释金将他们保释，并交由他们的
parents. By now, many residents of Stockton were hoping that the matter would go away, viewing Lee Lee's assault and murder as a tragedy that arose from a party that got out of hand. Other community members came to Lee's defense, with posters plastered all over town that depicted a drawing of three male figures, one of whom clutched a rock standing over a cowering girl. Across the image were the words, shame Stockton, shame, dob at the gutless bastards in. In an interview for Sticks and Stones, the killing of Lee Lee by the ABC, Stockton local Graham Parsons said the posters aims to break the code of silence that developed in the days
父母照顾。到目前为止，许多斯托克顿居民希望这件事能平息，将李·李的袭击和谋杀视为一场因派对失控而引发的悲剧。其他社区成员站出来为李辩护，镇上到处贴满了海报，上面画着三个男性形象，其中一人手里抓着一块石头，站在一个畏缩的女孩上方。图片上写着：“羞耻斯托克顿，羞耻，举报那些没种的混蛋。”在澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）制作的关于李·李被杀案的《棍棒与石头》（Sticks and Stones）采访中，斯托克顿当地人格雷厄姆·帕森斯（Graham Parsons）表示，这些海报旨在打破在李被谋杀后的几天里形成的沉默准则。
after Lee's murder. By the following day, all the posters had been torn down. Just over a month after Lee Lee's murder, Matthew Webster pleaded guilty to assaulting the 14-year old schoolgirl and of supplying cannabis at the party. Guy Wilson entered no plea and was eventually sentenced to six months. Corey pleaded guilty to sexual intercourse with a child between the ages of 10 to 16, but maintained that it was Lee who initiated the act. He was convicted and given a six-month sentence, which he appealed. At the appeal, a judge ruled that the sexual intercourse had been consensual, despite witness reports describing Lee as being so intoxicated she could barely stand and her distressed stayed afterwards. Corey's sentence was reduced to community service
到第二天，所有的海报都被撕掉了。在李·李被谋杀一个多月后，马修·韦伯斯特承认袭击了这名14岁的女学生，并在派对上提供大麻。盖伊·威尔逊没有认罪，最终被判处六个月监禁。科里承认与10至16岁之间的儿童发生性关系，但坚称是李主动发起的。他被定罪并判处六个月监禁，他对此提出上诉。在上诉中，法官裁定性行为是双方自愿的，尽管证人报告描述李当时醉得几乎站不稳，且事后处于痛苦状态。科里的刑期被减为社区服务，
for unlawful carnal knowledge. When news spread that a judge had ruled the sexual intercourse between Corey and Lee as consensual, public opinion of the murdered teen within her hometown was scathing. Her morals were described as loose and she was referred to as a good time girl and the town bike. She was even derided for ruining the lives of those who had been convicted of crimes in relation to her assault. Meanwhile, rumours regarding who killed Lee Lee and why continued to emerge. One prominent rumour implicated her stepfather Brad Shearman, with some accusing him of being in a sexual relationship with Lee. They speculated that when he came across Lee on the beach on the night of the party, she divulged that she had been
罪名是非法肉体关系。当法官裁定科里和李之间的性行为是自愿的消息传开后，家乡对这位被谋杀少女的舆论非常刻薄。她的道德被描述为放荡，她被称为“好玩女孩”和“镇上的公共汽车”。她甚至因为毁了那些因袭击她而被定罪的人的生活而受到嘲笑。与此同时，关于谁杀了李·李以及原因的传言不断出现。一个突出的传言涉及她的继父布拉德·希尔曼，一些人指责他与李有性关系。他们推测，当他在派对当晚在海滩上遇到李时，她透露自己遭到了
sexually assaulted. This caused Brad to explode in a violent rage that resulted in her murder. Although there was no evidence to support this theory, it was so persistent that police did view Brad as a suspect. However, aerial photography taken by a police helicopter of the Surf Club and adjacent beachfront displayed the tyre tracks made by Brad's motorbike during the time he was out searching for Lee. There were tracks all across the shoreline, except to the area where her body was found. Tensions remained high in the small town and on January 28, 1990, a group of four boys taunted Matthew Webster in the street about Lee's murder. Webster grabbed one of them and reportedly, quote, went off his head, smashing the boy through a car windscreen before thumping him repeatedly on the
性侵犯。这导致布拉德勃然大怒，从而导致了她的谋杀。虽然没有证据支持这一理论，但它非常顽固，以至于警方确实将布拉德视为嫌疑人。然而，警方直升机对冲浪俱乐部和邻近海滩拍摄的航拍照片显示了布拉德在寻找李期间，他的摩托车留下的轮胎痕迹。海岸线上到处都是痕迹，唯独发现她尸体的区域没有。小镇上的紧张局势依然很高，1990年1月28日，一群男孩在街上嘲笑马修·韦伯斯特关于李的谋杀案。韦伯斯特抓住其中一人，据报道，引文：“发疯了”，将那个男孩砸向汽车挡风玻璃，然后反复重击他，
ground. He was fined $250 for offensive behaviour. Brad Shearman was charged with assault when he punched Guy Wilson after he said that six-year-old Jessie Lee would suffer a fate similar to that of her older sister. Robin also endured a judgment and mistreatment at the hands of her local community, with some longtime residents believing if the family hadn't moved into the area, nothing would have happened. Even Jessie experienced harassment from other students at the kindergarten she attended, prompting Robin to pull her out of the school. On February 16, 1990, Matthew Webster and Guy Wilson were again interviewed by police in relation to Lee Lee's murder. The pair were initially questioned separately, then placed together
把他按在地上。他因冒犯行为被罚款250美元。布拉德·希尔曼在盖伊·威尔逊说6岁的杰西·李（Jessie Lee）会遭遇与她姐姐相似的命运后，打了威尔逊一拳，因此被控袭击罪。罗宾也忍受了当地社区的评判和虐待，一些长期居民认为如果这家人没有搬到这个地区，什么都不会发生。甚至杰西也在她就读的幼儿园受到其他学生的骚扰，促使罗宾让她退学。1990年2月16日，马修·韦伯斯特和盖伊·威尔逊再次就李·李的谋杀案接受警方询问。两人最初被分开询问，然后被安置在一起，
in an interview room that had been bugged with a covert listening device. However, neither teen said anything that incriminated themselves or any others in the crime. They were split up once more when suddenly Matthew Webster made an unexpected confession. Even though the 18-year-old was a suspect, police had no hard evidence against him. It seemed to come out of nowhere. Webster admitted, quote, Well, I did it, but I just couldn't believe it happened. It's just unbelievable. I went to look for my beers and I saw Lee Lee sitting down on the grass and my beers weren't there. Somebody must have pinched them. And then I walked up to Lee Lee and she carried on with
在一个安装了秘密监听设备的审讯室里。然而，两名青少年都没有说出任何对自己或他人不利的话。当他们再次被分开时，马修·韦伯斯特突然做出了意想不到的供述。尽管这名18岁的年轻人是嫌疑人，但警方并没有针对他的确凿证据。这似乎是突如其来的。韦伯斯特承认，引文：“好吧，是我干的，但我简直不敢相信发生了这种事。这太不可思议了。我去找我的啤酒，看到李·李坐在草地上，我的啤酒不在那里。肯定有人偷了它们。然后我走到李·李身边，她继续着她
her normal shit and I tried to get onto her. Then we walked down to the bushes and I pulled her clothes off and I pulled my shorts down. I thought I was right for a route and then she started pushing me away saying don't. I lost my temper and I did what I did. When asked to elaborate on his final remark, Webster said, She was punching and pushing and I grabbed her by the throat and she said don't and I choked her a bit. She stopped punching and I grabbed the rock and killed her. I thought she would squeal on me for trying to rape her. After the murder, Webster ran to a nearby boat ramp and washed his hands in a sink
平时的那套烂事，我试图对她下手。然后我们走到灌木丛里，我脱掉了她的衣服，拉下了我的短裤。我以为我可以爽一把，但她开始推开我说‘不要’。我失去了理智，做了我做的事。”当被要求详细说明他最后的话时，韦伯斯特说：“她在打我、推我，我抓住她的喉咙，她说‘不要’，我掐了她一会儿。她停止了反抗，我抓起石头杀了她。我以为她会因为我试图强奸她而告发我。”谋杀后，韦伯斯特跑到附近的船坡，在水槽里洗了手，
before sprinting home through the back streets. He met up with several other party goers at Roberto's pizza bar later in the night and told them he had left the party early to have a beer at the Stockton Hotel. He admitted to police that he told the others this lie to give himself an alibi. Despite the matter of fact manner in which Webster described assaulting and murdering Lee, he reportedly asserted, I am just so, so, so sorry. I would do anything to go back in time so it would not happen. I feel like a cunt. Matthew Webster was charged with Lee Lee's murder and sexual assault. He was refused bail and remanded in custody due to the serious nature of his charges.
然后穿过小巷跑回家。那天晚上晚些时候，他在罗伯托披萨店遇到了其他几个派对参与者，并告诉他们他提前离开了派对，去斯托克顿酒店喝了杯啤酒。他向警方承认，他告诉其他人这个谎言是为了给自己制造不在场证明。尽管韦伯斯特描述袭击和谋杀李的方式非常冷静，但他据报道声称：“我真的、真的、真的很抱歉。我愿意做任何事来回到过去，这样就不会发生这种事了。我觉得自己像个混蛋。”马修·韦伯斯特被控谋杀李·李和性侵犯。由于指控的严重性，他被拒绝保释并被还押候审。
Despite Matthew Webster admitting to sexually assaulting then murdering 14-year-old Lee Lee, some residents of Stockton rallied around the confessed killer, while the mistreatment of Lee's family continued. Their home was regularly broken into, and whenever Robin ran into any of the boys who had been at the party with her daughter, they would swear and spit at her. The relentless harassment and rumors had a profound impact on Lee's loved ones, with her biological father Robert attempting suicide in September 1990. Lee's stepfather, Brad, spent a week in a mental health facility, haunted by memories of her brutalized body and unable to cope with being viewed as a suspect
尽管马修·韦伯斯特承认性侵犯并谋杀了14岁的李·李，但一些斯托克顿居民仍支持这名承认杀人的凶手，而对李家人的虐待仍在继续。他们的家经常被闯入，每当罗宾遇到任何曾与她女儿一起参加派对的男孩时，他们都会咒骂并向她吐口水。无情的骚扰和谣言对李的亲人产生了深远的影响，她的生父罗伯特在1990年9月试图自杀。李的继父布拉德在精神健康机构住了一周，被她受虐尸体的记忆所困扰，无法承受被视为嫌疑人
in the crime. The pressure became too much for him and Robin, and the couple separated. The town remained divided between those who blamed the male perpetrators and those who blamed Lee Lee herself. As the word rape wasn't included in any of the charges filed in relation to the crime, it created the legal fiction that the sex acts committed against Lee were consensual. Fueling this belief was the judgment that Lee's outfit of a jumper, tank top, shorts and sneakers was revealing and thus inviting trouble. One local girl who was the same age as Lee told ABC Radio, a lot of people said Lee was a slut and she deserved it. I remember my mom telling me that little to nothing was done to pursue any others involved in the group attack on Lee,
的压力。这对夫妇最终分开了。小镇仍然分裂为指责男性肇事者的人和指责李·李本人的人。由于“强奸”一词没有包含在与该罪行有关的任何指控中，这造成了一种法律虚构，即针对李的性行为是自愿的。助长这种信念的是一种判断，即李穿着的毛衣、背心、短裤和运动鞋很暴露，因此招惹了麻烦。一位与李同龄的当地女孩告诉澳大利亚广播公司电台：“很多人说李是个荡妇，她是罪有应得。”我记得我妈妈告诉我，在追究其他参与集体攻击李的人方面，几乎没有采取任何行动。
but police assured her mother that the truth would come out during Matthew Webster's trial. However, by the time court proceedings began in October 1990 at the Supreme Court of New South Wales, the narrative had shifted from a violent gang assault and rape to an act of violence committed by a single person. On October 22, 1990, Matthew Webster pleaded guilty to murdering Lee Lee. The sexual assault charge had been dropped without explanation. A psychologist offered a possible motive, stating that Lee fighting off Webster's advances could have been perceived as the ultimate rejection, especially if he was under the impression that she had sexual intercourse with someone else earlier in the evening. The psychologist stated,
但警方向她的母亲保证，真相会在马修·韦伯斯特的审判中水落石出。然而，当1990年10月新南威尔士州最高法院开始审理此案时，叙事已从暴力团伙袭击和强奸转变为个人实施的暴力行为。1990年10月22日，马修·韦伯斯特承认谋杀李·李。性侵指控在没有解释的情况下被撤销。一位心理学家提出了一个可能的动机，称李反抗韦伯斯特的求欢可能被视为终极拒绝，尤其是如果他认为她当晚早些时候已经与别人发生了性关系。心理学家指出，
Webster attacked Lee Lee not so much because she would not let him have sex with her, but because she became the living proof that even someone he perceived to be a slut, the property of the clan, thought he was not good enough to have sex with her. At the conclusion of two days of court proceedings, Justice James Wood described Lee Lee's murder as totally unnecessary and totally preventable, though lay some of the blame at the feet of the parents of those who attended the party. He found it entirely reprehensible that the party took place without adult supervision. Quote, A duty is owed to all young persons to ensure that they are protected from the inevitable peer group pressures at functions such as this.
韦伯斯特攻击李·李与其说是因为她不让他发生性关系，不如说是因为她成了活生生的证据，证明即使是他认为的荡妇、部落的财产，也认为他不配与她发生性关系。在两天的法庭诉讼结束时，詹姆斯·伍德法官将李·李的谋杀案描述为完全不必要且完全可以预防的，尽管他将部分责任归咎于参加聚会的年轻人的父母。他认为在没有成人监督的情况下举行聚会是完全应受谴责的。引用如下：“对所有年轻人负有责任，以确保他们在参加此类活动时免受不可避免的同伴压力。”
Those pressures are exceedingly strong. They cannot be swept under the carpet. It should not have been left to the police to check on this party or to endeavor to exercise control over functions such as this. Police have other valuable work to do and the care of young teenagers cannot be delegated to them. It is the responsibility of parents who organize such parties or who allow their children to attend to ensure that they are appropriately supervised and that the children are properly counseled about the dangers in the use of alcohol and drugs and also in relation to intimate relationships. When Judge Wood spoke of what Lee had endured, his language suggested that she had not been raped,
这些压力非常大。它们不能被掩盖。不应该由警察来检查这个聚会或努力控制此类活动。警察还有其他重要的工作要做，照顾十几岁的青少年不能委托给他们。组织此类聚会或允许孩子参加的父母有责任确保他们得到适当的监督，并确保孩子们得到关于使用酒精和毒品的危险以及亲密关系的适当指导。当伍德法官谈到李所遭受的苦难时，他的措辞暗示她没有被强奸，
but rather had sexual intercourse. In reference to Matthew Webster, Judge Wood remarked, Generally, he has a reputation amongst friends and family of being a gentle, shy and polite young man who is somewhat lacking in self-confidence. On the basis of his reputation and antecedents, the offense would seem to be out of character. This prisoner is a first offender of otherwise good character. He behaved with uncharacteristic and impulsive ferocity whilst disinhibited by alcohol and drugs. He sentenced Matthew Webster to 20 years in prison with a non-parole period of 14 years. The ongoing diminishing of Lee's sexual assault devastated her family.
而是发生了性关系。在提到马修·韦伯斯特时，伍德法官评论道：“总的来说，他在朋友和家人中以一个温和、害羞、有礼貌且缺乏自信的年轻人的形象著称。根据他的声誉和前科，这种犯罪似乎与他的性格不符。该囚犯是初犯，且品行良好。他在酒精和毒品的影响下，表现出了与其性格不符的冲动凶残。”他判处马修·韦伯斯特20年监禁，不得假释期为14年。对李性侵犯事实的持续淡化摧毁了她的家庭。
Robin later told ABC Radio, Detective Sergeant Lance Chaffey said that yes, Lee had been gang-raped and yes, in his belief that Corey did rape Lee, but it was Corey's word against a dead person. He told me I had no say in whether others should be charged with Lee's murder or rape. He also told me this was a private conversation which he would deny publicly ever being a party to, so there was no point in me mouthing off about it to anyone. A feature article in the Sydney Morning Herald newspaper titled, In Cold Blood, perpetuated the victim blaming.
罗宾后来告诉澳大利亚广播公司电台，兰斯·查菲警长说，是的，李确实被轮奸了，是的，他相信科里确实强奸了李，但这只是科里的一面之词，而受害者已经死了。他告诉我，对于是否应该起诉其他人谋杀或强奸李，我没有发言权。他还告诉我，这是一次私人谈话，他会公开否认参与其中，所以我对此大吵大闹毫无意义。悉尼先驱晨报一篇题为《冷血》的专题文章，延续了对受害者的指责。
The article implied that Lee had instigated the sexual activity that occurred prior to her murder. Lee Lee had chosen November 3, 1989 as the day to make the move she had assured her mother was at least two years away. It also attributed blame to Robin, stating, Robin maintained an open mother-daughter relationship with Lee. Probably as a result of that relationship, Lee developed an outlook on life that was older than her years. They discussed sex often as Lee moved through puberty. Robin remembers that her daughter also developed quicker physically than her friends, assuming the body of a woman at age 14 that made her the subject of admiration among some girlfriends and the target of acute jealousy
文章暗示李在谋杀前挑起了性行为。李·李选择了1989年11月3日作为她采取行动的日子，而她曾向母亲保证那至少是两年后的事。文章还将责任归咎于罗宾，称：“罗宾与李保持着开放的母女关系。可能是这种关系的结果，李对生活的看法比她的年龄更成熟。随着李进入青春期，她们经常讨论性。罗宾记得她的女儿在身体发育上也比朋友们快，14岁时就有了女性的身体，这使她成为一些女性朋友羡慕的对象，也成为其他人强烈嫉妒的目标。”
among others. It also ensured that she acquired a trail of male admirers. The article quoted local priest, Father David Denley, who conducted Lee's funeral as saying, You don't see that many kids on the street at night now, which is a good thing. It is often said that something good often comes from the worst thing, and in this case, I suppose it is that parents have begun to question the level of control they exercise over their children. I think Stockton feels that it has been made a scapegoat for Australian society's realisation that too much freedom can have disastrous effects. After most of the publicity had died down, Robin was left with the realisation that others who
这也确保了她吸引了一群男性追求者。文章引用了主持李葬礼的当地牧师大卫·登利神父的话说：“你现在在街上看不到那么多孩子了，这是一件好事。人们常说坏事往往会带来好事，在这种情况下，我想是父母们开始质疑他们对孩子行使的控制程度。我认为斯托克顿觉得它已经成为澳大利亚社会意识到过多的自由会产生灾难性后果的替罪羊。”在大部分宣传平息后，罗宾意识到其他人
were involved in assaulting her daughter had never been charged, nor did it appear they ever would be. She and surviving daughter Jesse would ultimately be awarded a combined total of $29,214 in victim compensation, an amount deemed woefully inadequate by the family's supporters. Three years after her daughter's murder, Robin was forced to leave Stockton, unable to deal with the ongoing harassment, gossip, and public shaming directed towards her family on a daily basis. To many, she was the embodiment of an incident that the town longed to forget. Despite Stockton's efforts to move on, Lee Lee's case garnered the attention of various academics, including Associate Professor Kerry Carrington.
参与袭击她女儿的人从未被起诉，看起来也永远不会被起诉。她和幸存的女儿杰西最终获得了总计29,214美元的受害者赔偿金，这个数额被家人的支持者认为极其不足。女儿被谋杀三年后，罗宾被迫离开斯托克顿，无法应对每天针对她家人的持续骚扰、流言蜚语和公开羞辱。对许多人来说，她是这个城镇渴望忘记的事件的化身。尽管斯托克顿努力向前看，但李·李的案件引起了包括副教授克里·卡林顿在内的多位学者的关注。
Formerly of the University of Newcastle, Professor Carrington was a criminologist that had spent years examining every aspect of the case, and had become an outspoken advocate of Lee. Professor Carrington was of the belief that more than one person was involved in Lee's murder, and that the crime had come at the culmination of an escalation of degradation and violence over the course of the evening. She wrote that Newcastle culture seemed to exhibit a high level of tolerance for sexual violence among its adolescent population, and was critical of the sentencing remarks of Justice James Wood at the trial of Matthew Webster. Quote,
卡林顿教授曾任职于纽卡斯尔大学，是一位犯罪学家，她花了多年时间研究此案的方方面面，并成为李的直言不讳的倡导者。卡林顿教授认为，不止一人参与了李的谋杀，而且这起犯罪是当晚一系列堕落和暴力升级的顶点。她写道，纽卡斯尔文化似乎对青少年群体中的性暴力表现出高度的容忍，并批评了马修·韦伯斯特审判中詹姆斯·伍德法官的量刑意见。引用如下：
Justice Wood's judgment made no reference whatsoever to the sexual violence which the victim endured prior to her murder. His judgment expressed considerable concern about sexual promiscuity that occurred at the party attended by the victim and her assailants, and the lack of parental supervision. Justice Wood's judgment also considerably diminished the extent of collective violence inflicted upon Lee at the party just prior to her murder, stating, Only a small group of men mistreated her. She was critical of Justice Wood's description of Matthew Webster as a first offender of otherwise good character, who behaved with uncharacteristic and impulsive ferocity whilst
“伍德法官的判决完全没有提及受害者在被谋杀前所遭受的性暴力。他的判决对受害者及其袭击者参加的聚会上发生的性滥交以及缺乏父母监督表示了相当大的担忧。伍德法官的判决也大大淡化了李在被谋杀前在聚会上遭受的集体暴力程度，称：‘只有一小群男人虐待了她。’”她批评伍德法官将马修·韦伯斯特描述为“初犯，且品行良好，在酒精和毒品的影响下表现出了与其性格不符的冲动凶残”。
disinhibited by alcohol and drugs. In contrast, Professor Carrington pointed out that Lee Lee was represented in the judge's comments as a victim of parental failure and a willing participant in a wild party involving sexual promiscuity and the reckless consumption of drugs and alcohol. Quote, This reversing of the attribution of guilt and innocence rendered the victim the offender, and her attacker a victim. In January 1994, Professor Carrington received a letter that read, I am the mother of Lee Lee. For the last four and a half years I have been fighting for the
相比之下，卡林顿教授指出，李·李在法官的评论中被描绘成父母教育失败的受害者，以及参与涉及性滥交和鲁莽使用毒品和酒精的狂野聚会的自愿参与者。引用如下：“这种对罪恶与清白归属的颠倒，使受害者变成了罪犯，而她的袭击者变成了受害者。”1994年1月，卡林顿教授收到一封信，写道：“我是李·李的母亲。在过去的四年半里，我一直在为那晚真正发生的事情的真相而战。”
truth of what really happened that night. The way the police handled the whole case sickened me. I have written to anyone I could think of who could help me, but all the politicians, police, ombudsman, commissioner for human rights all ignored my pleas for help. I appreciate you standing up for Lee. People forget Lee was the victim, not the boys, Stockton, or the kids at the party, but Lee. I am praying to anyone who will listen to the truth on what really happened that night. Professor Carrington would later say it was this personal plea from Robin that spurred her deeper involvement and continuing research into the case. She arranged for the academics for justice to fund Robin's appeal against her inadequate victim's compensation payout,
“警方处理整个案件的方式让我感到恶心。我写信给任何我能想到的可以帮助我的人，但所有的政客、警察、监察员、人权专员都无视我的求助。我很感激你为李挺身而出。人们忘记了李才是受害者，而不是那些男孩、斯托克顿或聚会上的孩子们，而是李。我正在向任何愿意倾听那晚真正发生的事情真相的人祈祷。”卡林顿教授后来表示，正是罗宾的这种个人恳求促使她更深入地参与并继续研究此案。她安排了“正义学者”组织为罗宾对不足的受害者赔偿金提出的上诉提供资金，
and introduced her to a lawyer from the Newcastle Legal Center to represent her. They also wanted to have Lee Lee's case reopened so that there would be an official record that Lee had been raped. Professor Carrington also arranged for a number of new forensic opinions on Lee's autopsy report and other case materials. One of the experts she consulted, Dr Ruth Armstrong, said in her affidavit. As a female general practitioner, I examine normal and abnormal female genitalia on a daily basis. The injuries described to Lee Lee's genitals are consistent with non-consensual intercourse of an extremely violent nature. The deputy director of the New South Wales Institute of Forensic Medicine stated in their affidavit. I am of the opinion
并将她介绍给纽卡斯尔法律中心的一名律师来代表她。他们还希望重新开启李·李的案件，以便有一个官方记录证明李曾被强奸。卡林顿教授还安排了多份关于李的尸检报告和其他案件材料的新的法医意见。她咨询的专家之一，露丝·阿姆斯特朗医生在她的宣誓书中说：“作为一名女性全科医生，我每天都会检查正常和异常的女性生殖器。李·李生殖器上描述的损伤与极其暴力的非自愿性交一致。”新南威尔士州法医研究所副所长在他们的宣誓书中陈述：“我的观点是，
that it is much more probable that an inflexible object such as a beer bottle caused the majority of the genital injuries. In response to this assertion, Professor Carrington developed the theory that Lee Lee was raped and murdered as punishment for refusing her assailant's invitation to have sex. Forensic scientist Professor Harry Betcher concluded that Lee's fatal head injuries were indicative of someone having restrained her as Matthew Webster hid her. Questions had also been raised about Matthew Webster's confession as it didn't align with evidence from the crime scene. Webster claimed to have choked Lee with his left hand, but the bruising on her neck was consistent with a right hand. The clothing he wore on the night of the murder was clean,
啤酒瓶等坚硬物体导致大部分生殖器损伤的可能性要大得多。”针对这一断言，卡林顿教授提出了一个理论，即李·李被强奸和谋杀是因为她拒绝了袭击者的性要求。法医科学家哈里·贝彻教授得出结论，李致命的头部损伤表明有人在马修·韦伯斯特隐藏她时限制了她的行动。关于马修·韦伯斯特的供词也提出了质疑，因为它与犯罪现场的证据不符。韦伯斯特声称用左手掐住李，但她脖子上的淤青与右手一致。他在谋杀当晚穿的衣服是干净的，
despite the blows to Lee's head causing her blood to spatter 2.8 meters in one direction and 1.3 meters in another. A blood stain was found on the shirt worn by Webster's cohort, Guy Wilson, though it was not known whether any testing had been carried out on it. Following the murder, Webster described running to a nearby boat ramp to wash his bloodstained hands, yet it would have been less conspicuous and far easier for him to rinse his hands in the nearby surf. These inconsistencies led to the belief that more than one person might have been involved in the murder and that Matthew Webster had agreed to take the fall to protect them. Supporting this multi-perpetrator theory were assertions made by Professor Carrington,
尽管李头部的重击导致她的血液向一个方向喷溅了2.8米，向另一个方向喷溅了1.3米。在韦伯斯特的同伙盖伊·威尔逊穿的衬衫上发现了一处血迹，尽管不知道是否对其进行了任何测试。谋杀后，韦伯斯特描述说跑向附近的船坡清洗他沾满鲜血的双手，然而在附近的海浪中冲洗双手会更不显眼且容易得多。这些不一致之处导致人们认为可能不止一人参与了谋杀，而马修·韦伯斯特同意顶罪以保护他们。支持这一多肇事者理论的是卡林顿教授所做的断言，
who stated publicly on a number of occasions that she had obtained a witness statement that verified two people were involved in the murder. She told the press that she had reached out to numerous authorities about the statement, though no one was willing to take action on it. In May 1995, in what was described as a landmark legal decision, Judge Joseph Moore approved Robin's appeal from the decision of the victim's compensation tribunal. She and daughter Jesse were awarded an additional $134,048 for a total of $150,000 in compensation. Judge Moore found that Lee was subjected to a number of criminal assaults in the hours before her death, beginning with a rape perpetrated by 15-year-old Corey, whose actions had previously
她曾多次公开表示，她获得了一份证实两人参与谋杀的证人陈述。她告诉媒体，她曾就该陈述联系过众多当局，但没有人愿意对此采取行动。1995年5月，在一项被称为具有里程碑意义的法律裁决中，约瑟夫·摩尔法官批准了罗宾对受害者赔偿法庭决定的上诉。她和女儿杰西获得了额外的134,048美元赔偿，总计150,000美元。摩尔法官发现，李在去世前的几个小时里遭受了多次刑事袭击，首先是15岁的科里实施的强奸，他的行为此前
been deemed consensual by his appeal judge. The second act of violence Lee sustained was the group assault, in which she was surrounded outside and inside the surf club by a group of young men, then spat at, kicked, and verbally abused. According to an article titled, In Her Death, She Remains as the Limit of the System, by lawyer and PhD student Jonathan Morro and University of Sydney lecturer Mayra Sennroke, the appeal judgment named some of the boys involved in the group assault against Lee. One participant was her killer Matthew Webster, along with fellow event bouncer Guy Wilson. A number of other party goers were also identified, yet Judge Moore pointed out that one of the assailants and only one has been detected and
被他的上诉法官认定为自愿。李遭受的第二次暴力行为是集体袭击，她被一群年轻男子包围在冲浪俱乐部内外，然后被吐口水、踢打和言语辱骂。根据律师兼博士生乔纳森·莫罗和悉尼大学讲师迈拉·森罗克撰写的一篇题为《在她的死亡中，她仍然是系统的极限》的文章，上诉判决点名了一些参与针对李的集体袭击的男孩。其中一名参与者是她的杀手马修·韦伯斯特，以及活动的保镖盖伊·威尔逊。其他一些聚会参与者也被确认，但摩尔法官指出，袭击者中只有一人被发现并
charged with assault. As Matthew Webster's common assault charge had been upgraded to murder, Judge Moore was referring to Guy Wilson. The third and final act of violence committed against Lee, as described by Judge Moore, was sexual assault related to the act of murder. The judge supported claims that more than one person might have been involved in this attack and agreed that forensic evidence had shown that Lee had sustained, quote, a severe, violent, and resistant invasion of her body. Judge Moore's findings, coupled with the research by Professor Carrington and other academics, formed the backbone of a 300 page report by the Newcastle Legal Center to have Lee Lee's murder
被控袭击罪。由于马修·韦伯斯特的普通袭击指控已升级为谋杀，摩尔法官指的是盖伊·威尔逊。正如摩尔法官所描述的那样，针对李实施的第三次也是最后一次暴力行为是与谋杀行为相关的性侵犯。法官支持了关于可能不止一人参与此次袭击的说法，并同意法医证据表明李遭受了，引用如下：“对她身体的严重、暴力和抗拒性的侵犯。”摩尔法官的调查结果，加上卡林顿教授和其他学者的研究，构成了纽卡斯尔法律中心一份300页报告的骨干，旨在让李·李的谋杀案
reinvestigated. On July 26, 1995, the New South Wales Attorney General urged the State Minister for Police, Paul Wheelan, to reopen the investigation. Wheelan acknowledged that nobody had ever been charged with Lee's sexual assault and called the upcoming review an opportunity to right the terrible wrongs that occurred on the night that she died. In his statement to Parliament on October 15, 1996, Wheelan said, The New South Wales Crime Commission has the powers needed to get this job done, but it is time for those who know what happened to come forward. It is time to stop the lies and cover-ups and to set the record straight. It is time for the truth to come out.
重新调查。1995年7月26日，新南威尔士州总检察长敦促州警察部长保罗·惠兰重新开启调查。惠兰承认从未有人因李的性侵犯而被起诉，并将即将进行的审查称为“纠正她去世当晚发生的严重错误的机会”。在1996年10月15日向议会发表的声明中，惠兰说：“新南威尔士州犯罪委员会拥有完成这项工作所需的权力，但现在是那些知道发生了什么的人站出来的时候了。是时候停止谎言和掩盖，纠正记录了。是时候让真相大白了。”
As efforts were underway to reopen her daughter's case, Robin had to once again flee her home after receiving death threats from her detractors. One local woman told ABC Radio, I think that there was more involved, but I don't know whether it's too late to bring it up now. I mean, most people have got on with their lives. It's been seven years, and it's a sad thing for Matthew Webster's family for it all to be brought up again, and I think it's just been left too late, really. In his first ever address to the media following his conviction in 1990, Webster insisted he acted alone and was not covering for anyone else.
在重新开启她女儿案件的工作进行时，罗宾在收到诋毁者的死亡威胁后不得不再次逃离家园。一位当地妇女告诉澳大利亚广播公司电台：“我认为有更多人参与其中，但我不知道现在提出来是否太晚了。我的意思是，大多数人都继续他们的生活了。已经七年了，这一切再次被提起对马修·韦伯斯特的家人来说是一件可悲的事情，我认为这真的太晚了。”在1990年定罪后首次向媒体发表讲话时，韦伯斯特坚称他独自行动，没有为任何人掩盖。
The New South Wales Crime Commission released their findings on March 31, 1998, concluding that Lele's murder happened exactly as Matthew Webster had described, and that his sentence was adequate. While they accepted that some of the police investigation methods were improper, they did not lead to important, relevant facts being omitted for the purpose of sentence proceedings. Although they agreed that the evidence suggested other persons could have been charged with offences committed on the night of the murder, the commission found that police did not act inappropriately in failing to do so. They concluded that there would be no further action taken in relation to Lele's murder. In reference to the allegations
新南威尔士州犯罪委员会于1998年3月31日发布了他们的调查结果，结论是李·李的谋杀案完全按照马修·韦伯斯特所描述的那样发生，并且他的判决是适当的。虽然他们承认一些警察调查方法是不当的，但它们并没有导致为了量刑程序而遗漏重要的相关事实。尽管他们同意证据表明其他人本可以因谋杀当晚犯下的罪行而被起诉，但委员会发现警方在未能这样做时并没有采取不当行为。他们得出结论，关于李·李的谋杀案将不会采取进一步行动。关于指控
made by Professor Carrington in her various works on the case, the commission stated, they have each been investigated. Those that have not been reported on are regarded as groundless, as to the rest, most, but not all, are inconsistent with the commission's findings. The New South Wales Crime Commission only found fault in relation to the possible unlawful arrests of Matthew Webster and Corey, and referred this matter to the Police Integrity Commission. Among those called to give evidence before the Police Integrity Commission was Professor Kerry Carrington, though she was not informed why. Academic observers who worked alongside Professor Carrington expressed their opinion that she had been summoned, quote,
卡林顿教授在她关于此案的各种著作中提出的指控，委员会表示：“它们都已得到调查。那些没有被报告的被认为是毫无根据的，至于其余的，大多数（但不是全部）与委员会的调查结果不一致。”新南威尔士州犯罪委员会仅发现马修·韦伯斯特和科里可能被非法逮捕的问题，并将此事移交给了警察廉政委员会。在被传唤到警察廉政委员会作证的人中，包括克里·卡林顿教授，尽管她没有被告知原因。与卡林顿教授一起工作的学术观察员表达了他们的观点，即她被传唤，引用如下：
for the sole purpose of attacking her credibility on issues they had no intention of investigating, and to discredit someone who had attracted considerable media attention for criticising police. Professor Carrington had since released a book on the case titled Who Killed Lele? A Story of Shame and Mateship in an Australian Town, which was highly critical of the way police handled the investigation. During cross-examination, Professor Carrington revealed that her views of Lele's case had since changed following the release of the New South Wales Crime Commission report. She once thought it was a common-purpose murder and that other persons were involved in a criminological sense, though, now believed, Matthew Webster had, in a legal sense, acted alone.
“纯粹是为了攻击她在他们无意调查的问题上的可信度，并诋毁一个因批评警察而引起相当多媒体关注的人。”卡林顿教授此后出版了一本关于此案的书，题为《谁杀了李·李？澳大利亚小镇的羞耻与兄弟情谊的故事》，该书对警方处理调查的方式提出了严厉批评。在交叉询问中，卡林顿教授透露，在新南威尔士州犯罪委员会报告发布后，她对李·李案件的看法已经改变。她曾经认为这是一起共同目的谋杀案，并且在犯罪学意义上还有其他人参与，尽管现在认为，马修·韦伯斯特在法律意义上是独自行动的。
When asked to provide her current views on her past assertions that the police deliberately excluded evidence, Professor Carrington replied, In all honesty, I can say that's what I thought at the time with the material I had. On closer examination of the material, I didn't come to that conclusion. I've sat through six days of hearings here, I've read the Crime Commission report, and my views have changed. I held the view that there was an exclusion of material, but not that it was deliberate. The Police Integrity Commission rejected Professor Carrington's claims that the full details of Lele's autopsy report, including the extent of her genital injuries, were not among the brief of evidence provided
当被要求提供她目前对过去断言警方故意排除证据的看法时，卡林顿教授回答说：“老实说，我可以肯定地说，那是当时我根据手头材料所想的。在更仔细地检查材料后，我没有得出那个结论。我在这里参加了六天的听证会，我读了犯罪委员会的报告，我的观点已经改变了。我曾持有材料被排除的观点，但不是故意的。”警察廉政委员会拒绝了卡林顿教授的说法，即李·李尸检报告的全部细节，包括她生殖器损伤的程度，没有包含在提供给
to Justice James Wood during the trial of Matthew Webster. The Commission found that the full medical report was tended as evidence by the prosecution, and Justice Wood had it in his possession when handing down his sentence. They also addressed Professor Carrington's assertions that she had obtained a statement from a witness who had observed Lele's murder and declared two people were involved. In a televised interview in late June 1995, Professor Carrington stated that she had attempted to give the witness statement to the Attorney General, but was brushed aside as, quote, No one wants to take any responsibility for the mantle of justice here. When questioned about the statement during the Police Integrity
詹姆斯·伍德法官在马修·韦伯斯特审判期间的证据摘要中。委员会发现，完整的医疗报告是由检方作为证据提交的，伍德法官在宣判时拥有该报告。他们还处理了卡林顿教授的断言，即她获得了一份观察到李·李谋杀案的证人陈述，并宣称有两人参与。在1995年6月下旬的一次电视采访中，卡林顿教授表示，她曾试图将证人陈述交给总检察长，但被拒之门外，引用如下：“没有人愿意为这里的正义承担任何责任。”在警察廉政委员会听证会上被问及该陈述时，
Commission hearing, Professor Carrington conceded that it was penned by someone who had overheard others talking about the crime, and thus was a witness to admissions and not the actual murder. She admitted that she had never had in her possession her statement from a witness to the actual murder of Lele. The Police Integrity Commission review was released in October 2000. It found that the police had acted properly in their investigation into Lele's murder and reiterated that no one else would be charged in relation to the case. In one final blow to Lele's family, the Commission's findings offered Matthew Webster a possible avenue for appeal.
卡林顿教授承认，它是某人听到别人谈论犯罪后写下的，因此是关于供词的证人，而不是实际谋杀的证人。她承认她从未拥有过关于李·李实际谋杀案的证人陈述。警察廉政委员会的审查于2000年10月发布。它发现警方在调查李·李的谋杀案时行为得当，并重申不会有其他人因该案件被起诉。对李·李的家人来说，这是最后一次打击，委员会的调查结果为马修·韦伯斯特提供了可能的上诉途径。
There was evidence that he had been detained unlawfully when he was initially arrested, and quite likely had been assaulted by police at that time. In addition, 15-year-old Corey had not been provided an opportunity to contact his parents when he was arrested, despite being underage. The review had recommended the dismissal of Detective Sergeant Lance Chaffee who fronted the investigation for gross dereliction in duty in relation to the arrest. By all accounts, Matthew Webster's time in prison wasn't difficult. His potential avenue for appeal, as expressed by the Police Integrity Commission, didn't go anywhere, and in 2003, in preparation for his release, Webster started a program of day and
有证据表明他在最初被捕时被非法拘留，并且很可能在当时受到了警察的殴打。此外，15岁的科里在被捕时没有被提供联系父母的机会，尽管他未成年。审查建议解雇负责调查的兰斯·查菲警长，理由是他在逮捕过程中严重失职。据各方说法，马修·韦伯斯特在监狱里的日子并不难过。警察廉政委员会所表达的他的潜在上诉途径并没有进展，2003年，为释放做准备，韦伯斯特开始了为期一天和
weekend leave from prison. A few months before his parole hearing, he began work release, which permitted trusted prisoners to leave confinement to pursue employment and to report back at the end of the day. Webster's boss was pleased with his performance and intended to retain the convicted killer as an employee. 33-year-old Matthew Webster was granted parole in June 2004 after serving his minimum term of 14 years in prison, six years shy of his maximum. The New South Wales parole board stipulated that he not live in Stockton or the larger New Castle area for at least the next six years, meaning he was unable to live at his mother's house and could only visit under strict conditions. He instead moved into a halfway house in Sydney.
周末的监狱假。在假释听证会前几个月，他开始了工作释放，允许受信任的囚犯离开监禁去工作，并在一天结束时报告。韦伯斯特的老板对他的表现很满意，并打算留住这位被定罪的杀手作为员工。33岁的马修·韦伯斯特在服刑14年后于2004年6月获得假释，比他的最高刑期少了六年。新南威尔士州假释委员会规定，他至少在未来六年内不得居住在斯托克顿或更大的纽卡斯尔地区，这意味着他无法住在母亲家，只能在严格条件下探访。他搬进了悉尼的一家半途之家。
A news report at the time described Matthew Webster's family as, quote, relieved his crime has finally been forgiven. Now, they would like it to be forgotten. Within five months of his release, Webster was charged with assault after allegedly breaking another man's jaw. His parole was revoked and he was sent back to prison, but the charges were dismissed in April 2005 due to lack of evidence. A devastated and dejected Robin accepted that as long as she remained stonewalled by the community of Stockton, all avenues of justice for her daughter would remain closed. After a decade of doing all she could, Robin resigned herself to the fact that there was nothing more she could do
当时的一篇新闻报道将马修·韦伯斯特的家人描述为，引用如下：“对他终于被原谅感到宽慰。现在，他们希望这件事被遗忘。”在他获释后的五个月内，韦伯斯特因涉嫌打碎另一个人的下巴而被控袭击。他的假释被撤销，他被送回监狱，但由于证据不足，指控在2005年4月被驳回。心灰意冷、沮丧的罗宾接受了这样一个事实：只要她继续被斯托克顿社区拒之门外，她女儿的所有正义途径都将保持关闭。在做了十年她能做的一切之后，罗宾不得不接受这样一个事实：她再也做不了什么了
for Lee. In an attempt to make her feel better, the police told her what became of every person who had attended Jason Robertson's 16th birthday party. Some were in prison, others were drug addicts, and several were stuck in abusive relationships. Hearing about them is fortunate, did not bring Robin any sense of justice. The murder of Leely has been the subject of many academic papers and is taught in law schools throughout Australia as an extreme example of victim blaming in the community, media, and courtroom. Her case became the basis of the play The Property of the Clan, later renamed Blackrock, which was a fictionalized account concentrating on the fallout of a rape and murder at a teenage party. Blackrock was also made into a movie, however it featured one
为李做任何事。为了让她感觉好些，警方告诉她参加杰森·罗伯逊16岁生日聚会的每个人的下场。有些人进了监狱，有些人成了瘾君子，还有几个人陷入了虐待关系。听到关于他们的消息，并没有给罗宾带来任何正义感。李·李的谋杀案已成为许多学术论文的主题，并在澳大利亚各地的法学院教授，作为社区、媒体和法庭中受害者指责的极端例子。她的案件成为了戏剧《部落的财产》（后来更名为《黑岩》）的基础，这是一部虚构的作品，集中讲述了青少年聚会上强奸和谋杀的后果。《黑岩》也被拍成了电影，然而它有一个
major difference to its real-life inspiration. In the movie, a character named Jared witnessed the rape and breaks the code of silence, causing the murderer to end his life rather than be arrested. Jared is a fictional character with no real world counterpart, though he has been interpreted as a metaphor for everyone who witnessed Lee being assaulted, yet did nothing. As Professor Kerry Carrington explained, the brutal rape and murder of Leely, which followed hours of brutalization by a group of Stockton boys, is one of the most heinous crimes in recent Australian legal history. Yet, most of the boys involved in this extremely brutal crime have escaped prosecution completely and continue to be protected from prosecution.
与现实生活灵感的主要区别。在电影中，一个名叫贾里德的角色目睹了强奸并打破了沉默准则，导致凶手自杀而不是被捕。贾里德是一个虚构人物，在现实世界中没有对应者，尽管他被解读为目睹李被袭击却什么也没做的人的隐喻。正如克里·卡林顿教授所解释的那样，李·李在遭受斯托克顿男孩们数小时的残酷对待后被残忍强奸和谋杀，是澳大利亚近代法律史上最令人发指的罪行之一。然而，参与这起极其残忍罪行的大多数男孩完全逃脱了起诉，并继续受到保护，免受起诉。
On the day Matthew Webster was sentenced for the murder of her daughter, Robin was approached outside court by a woman who offered her a kiss on the cheek. Robin told the Sydney Morning Herald, quote, I'd never seen her before. She said she had a 14-year-old daughter and that she felt sorry for me. The same day, someone stole a basket of flowers from the top of Lee's grave. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在马修·韦伯斯特因谋杀她女儿被判刑的那天，罗宾在法庭外被一名妇女接近，该妇女主动亲吻了她的脸颊。罗宾告诉《悉尼先驱晨报》，引用如下：“我以前从未见过她。她说她有一个14岁的女儿，她为我感到难过。”同一天，有人从李的坟墓上偷走了一篮花。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。